hi welcome to the third of webinar in
this three-part series jointly produced
by Google and Intel my name is cara
Pandya and i have with me a guest from
Intel Thank You Kieran I'm sundar
Subramanyam I'm a technology evangelist
at Intel and today we are going to be
talking about ml side of things at the
end of the session will also do a Q&A so
please login in using your Google
Account to submit any questions hello
and welcome to the third and final
webinar in our series my name is Martin
Kronberg and I am a Technical Evangelist
with Intel hi and I'm Kara Pandya a
technology lead for machine learning for
partnerships at Google in the previous
two webinars we looked at how to collect
and send data using our gateway how to
query that data when it gets into GCP
using bigquery and then finally how to
visualize the results in data studio now
in this webinar we're going to show you
how to use that data to train a
predictive machine learning model all
right
so how are we gonna get what's the story
of this this webinar right so we're
gonna start with talking about machine
learning on Google cloud right the
high-level tools that we provide to help
you build your models next we're gonna
talk about the actual nitty-gritty of
building a model tensorflow the math
behind it all with that and then finally
I'm gonna walk you through a code demo
where we sort of walk through the code
that takes to build a model and then
we're gonna show you both hosting the
model in the cloud as well as on the
edge on IOT devices and gateways right
where you know things are happening if
you will at this point you're probably
thinking well I can probably I have the
right equipment in under my desk I can
start building a model here and you're
absolutely right however when you get to
building a model at scale to solve real
business problems your models are gonna
be large and what you're gonna need is
access to thousands of cores of compute
to go train this model right you're
gonna need tons in terms of memory and
CPU to go make that happen and what
Google Cloud does is we're very good at
being
able to provision thousands of course in
very short amount of time with short
amounts of times seconds at most right
to go build these models and we only
bill you by the minute so what ends up
happening is instead of you having to
worry about how am I gonna spool up a
cluster and manage all of this we take
care of that for you so instead of
planning out your budgets for you know
for the next three years how much does
my data science team need in terms of
compute you can just sort of you know
use it as necessary and get access to
effectively supercomputer levels of
performance now that we're talking about
building a ml model the start of this
journey is data you're gonna need tons
and tons of data to build models there
are some models that can go off with
small data sets there are some models
that go off of that need large data sets
to build the piece of advice I would
give here is don't start a journey of
gathering data first start by asking a
business question what is it that I want
to solve from there go to your data sets
go to your teams that manage your data
and make sure you have your data that
you already have collected cleaned up
where it's it's generally understood
there's no sort of random edge cases in
your data start with that right the data
is everything and companies that know
how to leverage this data will get ahead
and companies that don't will fall
behind like every large IPO that we're
seeing happen in these last few years
has machine learning and the utilization
of the data they've collected as a
pillar of the value prop of that company
right well like here I just said data is
really everything when it comes to
machine learning and in fact we're
talking about training a neural network
we're gonna need a lot of data so before
moving on I kind of want to talk about
how you as a developer can use Intel IOT
hardware and software to gather all the
data that we're gonna need for our
training so in this demo we're looking
at a use case of monitoring three
environmental variables in order to
detect anomalies in that data we're
gathering temperature sound and light
environmental data using three sensors
gathering and analyzing this kind of
environmental data can be extremely
in many different commercial sectors so
from monitoring a manufacturing process
to a smart buildings HVAC system or even
keeping track of individual workers
biometrics and what we want to do here
is create a prototype system which can
be applicable to all of these and really
any other application so in order to
gather the data we're using these groats
prototype sensors and these sensors are
meant for quickly being able to
prototype an IOT project they have these
sockets here which get two sets or pins
a power and a ground and that basically
means that you can use them without
having to breadboard or solder anything
and over all is gonna make your
development process a lot faster the
sensors are plugged into an Arduino 101
and the Arduino 101 is being used as a
sensor hub basically we're just using it
for its GPIO inputs as well as an analog
to digital converter all the control
logic is running here on our hook in
order to be able to read that sensor
data in we're using Intel's Emre and upm
libraries these libraries give
developers open-source sensor api's that
make reading and sensor data really
simple we cover all this in much greater
detail in our first webinar and if you
haven't already watched it I'd recommend
going back and checking it out what this
means in terms of data gathering is that
you can identify what the important
environmental data for your application
is and use inexpensive prototype sensors
as well as a simple API to read in all
that data quickly and easily and then
send it up to the GCP machine learning
service to start building up your ml
model so now that you've got the data in
the cloud and you're ready to go build a
machine learning model the question
becomes what is this machine learning
thing right machine learning engineers
like to use really big words around
concepts that really when you sit down
and sort of understand them boil down to
simple ideas right so machine learning
is basically where you take data sets
and then you apply algorithms to extract
an understanding of data so what used to
be the case of we had data scientists
who worked on one data set or
of them and like really understood the
problem space right and spent years sort
of being able to write these long sequel
queries to go extract that write
business answer instead now we're saying
let's just throw this algorithm at the
problem and use statistics to extract an
understanding of this data right and
that's all machine learning really is so
let's talk about what are the flavors of
machine learning fundamentally at Google
cloud we we sort of see two audiences
that use our tooling on one hand we have
ready to use models these are sort of
general problem space models where
things like you take a picture and you
want to identify the kind of dog in that
picture right and these models are
trained by Google engineers using
Google's massive scale and massive data
sets they're the same sort of technology
that powers like google translate so if
you same tech if you want it for your
business that's the ready to use models
next up we have an entire tooling
pipeline to help you build your own
models and sort of the target audience
there it's data scientists but this is
the same folks who had that deep
understanding of their data set to go
build their own neural network based
models and to end so that includes
things like scalable storage scalable
databases and warehouses like bigquery
which sort of give you the same
performance as your compute Rises right
and then we have what we called our
cloud machine learning engine that lets
you provision compute without sort of
doing the management side of things so
you can literally say one line of code
hey I want 10,000 cores to go run this
in parallel and we'll take care of that
okay um so if you wanted to recreate
some of these pre-built models using the
tools available are they powerful enough
to be able to actually recreate these
models definitely so the tooling that we
make available to you like cloud machine
learning engine is inspired by the same
internal tooling that in turn the
tooling we use internally at Google
right so just like kubernetes is
inspired by Google's container
management management system called Borg
same idea of like cloud machine learning
engine is sort of
we've gone through the hard part of
underst how do you actually do these
things at scale in production and then
we've brought the right pieces the
learnings to the table for you to just
use so it's a short answer yes you can
go rebuild the same thing as long as you
have the right data sets and that's sort
of where the differentiation comes in
right is that for general cases that are
like dog cat you know this the example
you always see hot dog not hot dog right
like that that kind of like identifying
the usual day exactly like those general
cases are api's do really well when
you're talking about things that are
like I took a photo of a part of my
production line in my business and I
want to have a model that understands
that I think that's that's where you're
starting to look into okay I need to
build a model I need my own data set to
go do that and that's where the
toolchain part comes in okay so going
back to the machine learning api's we
call these pre trained models api's
because you interact with them as easily
as you would any web api these api's
make available to the public the machine
learning sort of models that were built
by Google experts they're trained as I
said earlier on our massive data sets
and heavy-duty machine learning with
thousands of cores is going on behind
the scenes but you don't need to learn
any machine learning to use these we
currently have five more coming soon so
let's do a quick journey of the five of
them first up the vision API this tells
you information about images if you give
it an image and it will detect and label
it saying hey here's a dog here's an
alaskan malamute
in this picture it detects faces and
does sentiment analysis so if you're
thinking along the lines of hey when
photos of my brand show up in a Twitter
feed are only a hashtag are people happy
or sad do people generally correlate
happiness with my brand you can start
extracting this right and then finally
it extracts text from images and Flags
inappropriate content so if you're doing
OCR at scale you can use our API to
extract the text and then get relevant
business data back out of it and so once
again this was trained using the Google
image repository which is massive
and there's sort of this feedback loop
going on there right where the models
are helping you find the images which
were then using to make our original
model even better so it's a feedback
loop that just keeps getting better and
better and you just have to use an API
and you get the power of Google for your
business case so all right next up
natural language API the natural
language API is all about understanding
text it will extract and label important
key words it does sentiment analysis
just like you know the face analysis it
tells you if the email you got to your
support cue has a really angry customer
you know mad about your product and you
can prioritize it right instead of Auto
responding to the customer saying hey we
will get back to you in 24 hours like we
always you know dudes that your auto
responses maybe you can send them back a
coupon code saying hey we recognize that
you're angry we're prioritizing we're
sorry here you go and that potentially
saves a lifelong customer relationship
put it together the API is useful for
analyzing what people are saying about
your products at scale it helps you
support multiple languages with advanced
syntax analysis so case in point you get
an email to your English support QQ but
it's someone asking a question in
Spanish instead of just saying sorry we
only support English as a response you
can now come back and have at least a
semi helpful response in addition to
saying maybe we can't we don't you know
do Spanish support directly next up the
speech API the speech API is for voice
recognition it is the same core
technology that powers Google voice
search Google home Google assistant
we've put in billions of dollars of
effort into building this into
internationalization and we now support
80 languages it is robust to noise has a
fast streaming API so you can literally
build similar scenarios as the Google
assistant and you can customize it by
passing it word hint so if you have
specific words that are common in your
industry you can have a tweaked version
of the API that will understand that and
sort of give you back the text result
next up the translation API the
translation API translates over a
hundred languages and thousands of
language pairs back and forth between
each other
we launched a premium edition of this
little while ago and one of the
breakthroughs Google has had in this
space is earlier in the year we started
launching our deep neural network based
models for translation so before that
happened everybody who was doing
translation was primarily doing
translation based using sort of phrase
based classical machine learning models
Google literally spends weeks and months
training neural network models now where
we're getting to like real-time
translation we're getting to the point
where we can support the same accuracy
as a human would be translating
real-time so there's some amazing stuff
going on there next up is the beta video
API so at Google next 2017 in San
Francisco we announced an ml API for
extracting insights from video the first
set of this functionality lets you
analyze a video across sort of the time
dimension and say from a given timestamp
to another what is happening in a video
so you can say hey there is a tiger in
this video from a gift you know from
timestamp X to X plus y whatever that
may be and so the in that set an API
that we announced recently and more
continuing to iterate on so expect more
information on that soon putting all of
that together the best part of all of
this is you don't need an account you
don't need to go set up anything you can
try these all in the browser you
literally just click click go so I
encourage you to play with them on your
own it takes 10 minutes to validate the
effectiveness of everything that I just
said so go keep me honest right the
barrier to entry is extremely low right
and once you guys are done kind of
exploring these in the browser you might
want to learn about how to implement
them on the Gateway and you know as
Karen said there's really no reason to
create your own custom model if a model
already exists and it does what you need
to do so as an example let's take a look
at how we can use that speech-to-text
model to transcribe a piece of recorded
audio on our note gateway so for this
example we're going to be using the GCP
SDK for Python to interface with the
speech recognition model assessor
gateway does not come with GCP SDK by
default
we're gonna have to install and
configure it before getting started so
we're going to install the cloud SDK and
then the Python module we can do that by
simply using apt-get for the cloud SDK
and then pimp to install the python
module now it's important that you
initialize the SDK before trying to
communicate with GCP in webinar one we
authorized our connection to the IOT
core service by using a public/private
key pair that we had to generate here
we're going to be using the SDK to
authorize access to the Google machine
learning models so no need for
generating your own keys you can do that
from the command line interface
basically run g-cloud init navigate to
that URL that's generated and login once
you log in and allow the SDK to access
Google services you can set a default
Geographic zone if you want and that's
all you need to do in order to setup and
authorize the SDK once the SDK is setup
we can write our script that will send
an audio file up to GCP for processing
the API itself is pretty simple we
basically import the speech package from
Google Cloud module create a speech
client read in our audio file set the
parameters of that audio file and then
send the audio file to GCP for a
response now keep in mind that there's
gonna be a few extra bits of code to
make this all work
but in principle this is all that you
need also in this example we're sending
a local file to the speech recognition
model but it's also possible to send a
remote file stored on Google Cloud or a
streaming file using a microphone pretty
powerful stuff that's wrapped up in a
really simple API so let's get into the
details of the latest wave in ml the
resurgence of neural networks neural
networks are a construct built by
connecting lots of perceptrons together
neurons if you will a perceptron is just
a function that has a conditional value
perceptron can be designed to
effectively host any mathematical
function to calculate a value
that's all it is really so chaining
together a bunch of these together lets
us build complex high dimensional
relationships in the model to capture
from the data a neural network ml model
is just a structure perceptrons with
each layer performing a specific
operation and then feeding its output to
the next layer in the case of tensorflow
the actual asset is a model file that
once trained is portable and reusable
the data scientists job is to figure out
the best structure of this ML model that
that results in a model that can capture
the patterns the statistical patterns
within the data so that you can then use
that to predict future statistical
patterns that's neural networks what is
deep learning neural networks as an ml
technique actually fell out of flavor a
couple of days after the original Minsky
paper came out and part of the reason
for that was we did not have enough
computer hardware to actually solve any
real significant problems using that
pattern this has changed rapidly in the
last decade or so leading to the rise of
deep learning a deep learning model is
nothing more than a neural network with
lots and lots of layers and we're
talking in some cases with some of the
larger google models now millions and
millions of neurons making hundreds of
layers there are multiple sort of ML
techniques to train these deep neural
networks so let's step into sort of each
one of them in terms of like how would
you train one of these large networks so
first up is supervised learning or where
you learn by example where you have sort
of when you think about like hey I have
a big data set where I can I know the
right answer for each set of input
problem data points
that's where supervised learning comes
in second there's unsupervised learning
here you rely on the ML model to find
and predict patterns in data where there
isn't necessarily a right answer right
an example would be by looking at people
moving around in a store can you predict
shoplifting right and to do that you're
effectively sort of trying to build
clustering in terms of movement patterns
of how people move in the store and see
relationships form out of that
a third sort of the most exciting
ongoing research right is we have
reinforcement learning this technique
utilizes trial and error patterns where
the computer learns by actually doing
the task again while the core research
in this space goes back decades we're
seeing a resurgence of its application
and new groundbreaking research emerging
now because of the availability of
compute right the cloud in some way it's
because that compute doesn't have to be
pre purchased up front you again just
get as much as you need for the period
you need it right so for instance when
Google Image Search returns something
that you're not expecting that's
actually a way of it learning what it
should be yes and no so that's actually
a good point I should highlight the
difference right when I'm talking about
learning real-time what I'm talking
about is the case of think of it as a
robot that I can teach to manipulate
objects where the robot isn't explicitly
given a set of instructions or here's
how you move an arm closer to the ball
the robot just is looking at a ball and
it's arm and it learns it's crazy as it
sounds it learns to figure out how to
pick up the ball and put it in the hole
right like that is what we're talking
about what you're talking about is sort
of a concept code that overloaded term
called online learning where real time
as humans give feedback to the pattern
live like the model itself improves and
knows that hey this picture that I
thought was a dog is not really a dog
but that's not directly reinforcement
learning hmm so another good example of
reinforcement learning was that it was
successfully used by Google that the
google deepmind team to build to beat
the the the top go player in the world
the computer was able to figure out
unconventional moves right people were
watching the live stream they at that
particular move they had they all go
wait that move makes no sense nobody
should be doing that move in that in
that particular case and the computer
did that because it could predict the
outcome of the entire game all the way
to the end and that was taught by
reinforcement learning and that now has
gotten better and
with a computer played against itself to
get better because there weren't humans
that were good enough to beat it right
so that's sort of where we are with
reinforcement learning all right so
let's talk about some common machine
learning tasks there's a list up there
let's go through that classification so
dog or a cat going back to that example
what kind of bolt is this if it's a
industry specific model right classes of
objects and trying to figure out what
fits where next up regression think of
it is you have a graph and you're trying
to predict the direction of that line in
the graph the next few steps right
that's sort of what you're talking about
then there's similarity where I have a
picture of a Alaskan Malamute show me
pictures of more Alaskan Malamutes and
not Siberian Huskies right that's sort
of similarity they're ranking you see a
lot of this and you go to go purchase
something online and how does the the
backend system decide that it should
show you what list of products but not
just that but in what order right which
one should be at the top because that's
the highest probability you're gonna
probably you know see it click it
purchase it so ranking and then there is
sequence prediction where type-ahead so
can I start pre typing for you right
like what you see you know your phone
suggests the next few words and sequence
prediction or again the demo we're going
to show where can you predict the
temperature readout of a sensor to then
detect anomalies and then the last bit
again not the least dimensionality
reduction where say you have lots of
options you want to pick one or pick few
so this sort of goes hand in hand in
some ways with the the prediction but
the retail example that I gave all right
so one of the core tenets of machine
learning right is anytime you're trying
to build a model you'll end up dealing
with cost functions so this is sort of
where we get into the nitty-gritty of
the math of this if you will a cost
function basically quantifies the Delta
between what a model predicted versus
the truth or the reality that is trying
to model the process of training a model
is basically an iterative thing where
you take lots of predictions from the
model
you calculate this loss this cost if you
will right there I'm overloading terms
but effectively think of it like
calculate that Delta and then you go
back and adjust that model so that the
the inner sort of weights if you will of
the model are adjusted to get to produce
that loss and then you start again do it
again with the next batch of data and
the next batch of data and as you can
imagine hundreds of thousands of these
iterations later the model gets very
good at given a set of inputs it gives
you that set of outputs so how do you
reduce this loss one of the ways to
reduce loss functions is to use an
algorithm called gradient descent I'll
skip the mathematical details of the
algorithm here but for one point the
algorithm itself is relatively simple to
implement but implementing it across
multiple machines to build a modern
large-scale model is very hard you've
just solve all sorts of problems and
challenges around managing the cluster
connecting them together all of that
craziness tensorflow makes this easier
while also providing other scenario
specific reduction algorithms right
again I'm not gonna go into detail here
but you have a list of choices where
they one might be better than another
depending on the exact model right and
that's where the data scientist comes in
you can use these these pre-built models
and algorithms and libraries aren't
tensorflow to make your engineering
process easier so that your devs and
your data scientists and your business
people can work together to solve the
business problem and the data science
and not necessarily the how do I bring a
set of machines together to work
together to solve an algorithm now let's
say you're along your journey of
building this model one of the things to
be very careful about is overfitting no
model is 100% accurate building a good
model involves trading off between
multiple metrics to prevent
again overfitting overfitting is where
the model after training is over
specialized for the training data but
not generalize enough to be useful for
new data one of the techniques used for
example here is regularization which
imposes additional cost on model
complexity my header point here is that
in this space as well performing there
are some high-level things that your
data scientist has to be aware of but
there are some programmatic things that
you can do as well
and tensorflow has tooling for you to go
do that in a way that says hey call a
couple of functions and then it takes
care of that problem for you so this
goes back to the larger set of choosing
the right tools and not building them
all so as he consents there is a theme
here let's talk about the theme that the
tools right you don't build your own
library for measuring time right the y2k
bug you like go back to decades
the reason that happened was everybody
was writing their own date calculation
function and it's complex and it's hard
and you know what there's no business
value in doing that so instead of going
to do that rely on something that does
the mundane for you so you can solve the
high value problem
so why tensorflow then there are other
options that have lots of libraries as
well well here's the thing
off the other tooling chains that are
available tensorflow is the most popular
this right here is a measure by github
stars we have massive amounts of public
contribution we work directly with the
community and is the fastest growing
sort of community platform for machine
learning today so it's a model that's
trained in text reflow compatible with
the other tooling frameworks actually
yes it is so let me give you an example
the Charis api is a higher-level API
that lets you sort of simplify even some
of the dialects that tensorflow uses to
build certain kinds of models that API
is something for example Apple now
supports in their core AI platform core
ml I'm sorry so you can train using
Kerris the end result is a tensorflow
model but this can now run on an iPhone
in Apple stack so the one of the core
tenets of the tensorflow design was you
could swap out the underlying execution
environment but the model itself is a
self-contained asset that can run
anywhere so previously it used to be you
would have you would deploy something
like spark and then
an algorithm you wrote the trainer model
but then portability was sort of an
afterthought and this was put right up
front
actually that sort of brings me back to
the point of why is it so popular right
because it's it's flexible enough for
research but performant and portable
enough for production it's very rare to
have a single framework that does both
of these things well traditionally you'd
model your problem on a developer
friendly framework and then you would
come back and sort of your production
team would say okay we get the math of
this let us write this in a way that
actually scales right tensorflow takes
care of that because the model lets lets
you go from sort of an environment where
you're sort of IDE iterating you know
coming up with maybe this model works
better and then just taking that asset
and running in production the popularity
of tensorflow also means that you'll
have a vibrant community of fellow
developers to reach out and get for help
which you know for example Stack
Overflow you know we've got like our
engineers are reaching out and working
with this community so if you do get
stuck on something we're done you know
we or the community is there to help
all right so let's get into the
specifics of the model we built here
right
we built what's called an LS TM it's a
long short-term memory it's a deep
neural network pattern where the model
can effectively build a concept of a
memory it's not a stateful machine per
se but it has the concept of taking a
set of data points off from the past and
then being able to predict the next data
point because it can look at a sequence
in the in the input data this pattern is
often used in situations where there's
some periodicity to the data right
there's a rhythm maybe there's a
sequence any of that and that's what
makes it a great fit for detecting
anomalies and streaming IOT sensor data
because there's a periodicity right your
temperature goes up goes down there is a
rhythm of business that applies and
analyst team can learn that so how does
that work the way this works is that the
model is trained by giving it a set
amount of time slices of data in getting
it to predict the next few steps then so
when you're doing that you're doing that
over lots and lots of time slices of
data then at runtime similar inputs are
provided real
time and the model predicts the next few
data points these next few data points
are then compared to the real-world
measurement using multiple methods like
thresholds accumulators and gaussian
techniques relying on variance once the
Delta between the model prediction what
the model thinks should be happening in
the real world
triggers whatever your threshold
algorithm is your measure is now you
know you have an anomaly because over
the set of the clean data you trained it
on that didn't happen so let's say you
had a temperature sensor and it expects
a gentle shift in temperature and there
is a fire well the temperature is gonna
shift really fast it's gonna trigger an
anomaly right so basically the
difference between it getting warmer
throughout the day versus its spiking up
exactly exactly and then the more
sophisticated you get to with the actual
detection side of things so there's a
prediction and then the detection and
there are techniques like you can use a
neural network itself for the detection
side of things but putting all that
together what it helps you do is instead
of the old system of setting a threshold
or if it gets above 90 degrees Celsius
there's probably a fire instead of that
let's say your server room does get hot
it has big swings in temperature for
whatever reason right just
hypothetically your model understands
that so it doesn't just trigger every
time there's you know an event that is
expected to happen on the third Tuesday
of every month so there's something like
that right if you can train that into
the model right all right so let's jump
right into the code here what I have in
front of me is Google Cloud Data Lab
which is a version of it's an
open-source version of the Jupiter
notebooks which have been modified to
just make it easy for you to do things
like push jobs and to cut into Google
Cloud like solve the authentication
challenges and things like that all
right so what's on screen right now is
my folder of code files that is used to
Train this model there is the model file
model duppy Y which defines the tensor
flow graph for the model itself the
setup file as the name indicates is
setting up dependencies things like that
that you may need installed on the apps
kill machines and then finally there is
the task file which manages the multi
machine
of like how do you get this bottle on
multiple machines let's go through each
one real quick first up this is the
model file I'm not going to step through
the details of each piece of code here
we will be sharing a blog post at the
end of this video that has all of this
really well detailed but I want to do
want to take a moment to highlight that
some some key pieces here that come into
play the recurring theme that I kept
sort of harping on earlier was don't use
the building blocks that exist for
tensorflow don't rebuild them this is a
very good example of that in creating
the tensor flow graph the to build an LS
TM you should not be starting from
connecting bits of neurons together that
doesn't make sense
instead what I'm doing here is using the
basic lsdm cell that tensorflow already
provides to simplify my tasks I can just
connect together bigger and bigger
pieces to solve the larger problem
that's part of the model next up at a
higher level the task file which does
the orchestration instead of again
managing the execution and split of the
data across hundreds of hundreds of
machines what we're doing here is using
the TF learn estimator API this API
takes care of all of those those sort of
difficulties for you so that you take
the model you pointed out data and you
say go and the estimator API takes care
of sizing up the data sets running them
in parallel and combining the results
for you again another example of not
reinventing the wheel yourself now that
the codes ready you need to run it that
brings me to this other piece of code
here that actually starts the cloud
machine learning job and what's
happening here is we're taking those
files combining them into a task called
trainer tasks in this case right here
and we're telling cloud machine learning
engine hey run this in the region I
defined here US central one with these
other parameters and at this scale this
this this knob about setting the scale
for your job is is something you control
to say how many resources you want
to to run this training on for example I
have run trainings where have literally
requested thousands of cores with a
similar config file and it will give
that to me and I won't have to do any
management and I will only pay by the
minute
so once you submit the job the job
becomes a machine learning engine job
which you can on the Google cloud
console track as its running look at the
logs all of that and then finally it
tells you how many ml units had consumed
at the end of the job so that you always
know what each specific training event
costs you the output of this job is a
train model which was set we set the
target output directory as a flag that's
what this directory looks like and
there's a bunch of extraneous files here
generally concerned around resuming
training and all of that the file in
question here is the graph PB text this
file is the entirety effectively up here
are a few tensorflow model including the
the structure and the weights and all of
that so now that you have that cloud
machine learning engine also has a way
to just like it had a training job as a
way to host files for you in an auto
scaling platform so you never have to
worry about how do I you know actually
use this model so let's move over to a
cloud function that I have written that
lets you every time there's a new
temperature reading from the device this
function gets triggered it looks what it
will do then is grab the last nine
readings from bigquery going back to
sort of the work that was done in
webinar two that data is then used to
predict what should be the tenth reading
according to the model so we ask Google
ml engine to create that prediction
based on the model we had given it that
prediction is then compared to the
actual tenth prediction that triggered
this function we look at the Delta in
this case a very simple threshold and if
the threshold is exceeded we log that
there was an anomaly again in this case
you could do whatever other action that
was needed in the case of an anomaly so
this was running in the cloud
but with IOT you might not have good low
latency reliable connectivity how do you
solve for that and the way you do that
is you move the model closer to the edge
onto your gateways onto your edge
devices so Martin you want to talk about
that a little bit sure what we can look
at here is a bit of a hybrid model where
we train our ml model in the cloud using
the Google Cloud api's and then run that
model locally on the Gateway so like you
mentioned earlier training a ml model
requires a huge amount of compute power
and way more than is gonna be available
even on the highest-end gateway type
device so we can also that task to the
cloud where we have access to all that
power we can set up the sensor data we
can run the training and we can generate
a training model so instead of running
that model in the cloud we can run that
model locally and running the model
locally means that you have to set up
your compute environment locally and
you're also gonna have to be limited by
the compute power that you have
available on your local device however
the trade-off being that you are no
longer bound to the cloud service to run
your model so let's say that our
application uses an ml model to run a
real-time control system of some kind
that has a low tolerance for any kind of
latency in that case by running the
model locally we can avoid having to
deal with any latency issues that can
arise from leveraging a planet-scale
cloud analytics platform like GCP
likewise if we're using our model to run
a control system we don't want that
control system to stop functioning
completely if it loses connection to the
Internet I can imagine something like
this being used for let's say monitoring
a trade that can pass through regions
without internet connectivity or just go
through a tunnel and lose service
completely once again if we run the
model locally we won't have to worry
about losing our control system if we
lose connectivity finally there could be
an issue of the amount of raw data that
is being fed into our model in this
example we're passing in a single
temperature reading once a second which
is a fairly trivial amount of data
but we can imagine an application where
we actually have to send a non-trivial
amount of data to the model for
processing if instead of a single
reading once a second you have to send a
hundred readings or a thousand readings
once a second you can start to run into
bandwidth issues so once again running
the model locally we can get around
those issues so that's kind of the
reasoning behind why we might want to
run a train model locally and let's just
take a quick look at how we can do that
on our Gateway we can run our train
model on a local instance of tensorflow
and since our Gateway is running a bun -
and texture flow is an open source
platform there's really no issues
installing it and getting it running you
can get your environment set up in a few
ways so first we can use pip to just
install the Python modules in the user
environment we can also use a virtual
environment to create an isolated Python
environment and it's all attempts to
flow inside that and finally we can use
docker to install an entire isolated
docker image with tensorflow
installed inside I would say that if you
are running many Python applications on
your gateway that an isolated
environment is the preferred way of
going but if you're only running
tensorflow the simpler local install is
probably what you'd want to do now all
ready to run our model when trading our
model we generate a protocol buffer file
or a dot PB which contains the graph
data about our models as well as the
weights the gradients Tobias's basically
all the information that we need to
recreate that neural network by loading
this file into tensorflow we can rebuild
that model that was trained in the cloud
and then start passing sensor data into
that model it's going to monitor the
sensor data and predict what it thinks
the next temperature value is going to
be and we can load all these parameters
into tensorflow using a load module API
once the model is loaded we can run our
temperature data array through the model
we read the temperature data using our
sensor API temp dot read and then we run
our model the model is going to output a
predicted next temperature value based
on nine previous temperature readings
we can compare the predicted value to
the actual reading and decide if that
Delta is high enough to label it as an
anomaly now keep in mind that we're
gonna have to match the data format that
the bottle was trained with so we're
gonna have to pass in an array of nine
temperature values every single time in
order to get an output for the tenth
value all right so that's all we have
for today folks we hope that this
session really helps you start solving
real business problems with machine
learning you know start your journey get
machine learning implemented into your
business yeah and thank you again for
tuning in and I really hope that this
whole series of webinars really inspires
you to go out and create outtie
solutions for yourselves we'll see you
guys next time
you
all right welcome back hopefully the
material in that recording was helpful
to you
so we've collected some questions along
the way that came up in the lab chat and
otherwise so let's just jump right into
them the first one was how much data do
you need to train a model like this
particularly around LS DMS so the the
the way to think about the data
requirements are think about the
periodicity that you're trying to build
into your model so for example if you're
if you have a temperature sensor in a
room that is very climate control that
has very narrow ranges that don't change
a lot
then you need a short window of data to
train this model and then it will detect
anytime there is an anomaly if you've
got say a temperature sensor inside a
refrigerator truck that sees significant
shifts in temperature right the air
conditionings turned off at night when
it's parked all of those things then you
will need more data over time as the
struck travels you know took the United
States or whatever it may be to build
that period of periodicity back into the
data so there isn't a strict sort of
megabytes gigabytes terabytes
requirements more about what you're
trying to model so here's another one
what kind of sensors to the Intel sensor
library support the upm sensor library
supports about 400 different sensors and
actuators from low end all the way to
like industrial commercial grade sensors
you can monitor like variety of
environment variables temperature
pressure gas or moisture and and so on
and over a different kind different
kinds of protocols as well Wi-Fi z-wave
ZigBee ble USB Modbus etc so take a look
at upm dot MRA eight or IO and you'll
get a lot more information about what
these libraries can do for you awesome
all right next up so what are some good
resources to learn modern machine
learning and deep learning so I'd say a
couple of things to do number one
Coursera has a few courses on deep
learning but what I'd suggest you do is
you start from the the older sort of
machine learning course that's
available on Coursera what it'll do is
it'll help you build a good foundation
around what are the sort of traditional
techniques that were around before
neural networks came along and became
more popular not even came along became
more popular and then how they're
related and then from there you can do
the deep learning course that was
recently launched on Coursera and I
think that's a very good sort of ramp up
to then figure out where you want to go
deep because if the field is really wide
and really deep the other thing I would
add is Google has what we call code labs
available so if you just search
tensorflow code lab one of the first
results should be a code lab that this
for a tensor flow without PhD without
PhD if you will and that's a great start
because it gives you a very quick
rundown on everything you learn from the
Coursera course how it applies to what
look with real tensor flow code so
that's where I would say you should
start cool right so the next question I
think is this one's more relevant for
for what you're covering which is the is
it is it one model per sensor right or
is there a way to build a model for
temperature sensors across a facility so
sure I can take that one so the way I
think that you should think about that
again is the it's not one model per
sensor but what you're again going back
especially in an lsdm kind of pattern
what you're trying to build is a
coherent model of what's happening in
the real world over time so you could do
one model per sensor if you're deploying
this on each sensor and then do some
training at the sensor or the other
pattern is collect groups of sensors
that observe a connected environment in
some source that pattern works really
well so again if you have sensors across
a warehouse you can take all of this
data and effectively where I was putting
in in the in the in the code you saw a
basically a vector of time of
temperature measurements for one sensor
it would be a matrix of measurements
across time and then you could train a
model that way but again sort of start
from the perspective of what is the MOT
what what environment am i trying to
model and then go from there and then
pick the right tool for the job
all right so I want to use a microphone
to do streaming video a wise to text
locally using a nuke what's the best way
to do that that sounds like an
interesting project yeah so the one one
way to do it would be to pick a
microphone that has support for Ubuntu
right I pick a pick a microphone that
has like a USB support and then plug it
into the nuke you'd also want to a
recording software to record the audio
and then send are the audio chunks to
the Google ml API in the webinar and if
you're sticking with Python you can use
a PI audio that would work and then you
can chunk the audio and then send them
to to the ml api's but one thing that I
recommend is make sure that these
samples are wrong enough that probably
say about 100 milliseconds or longer
would be a good idea but good luck with
the project yeah and I'd add one more
thing the API supports both synchronous
and asynchronous audio so if you want to
do something like a Google assistant
scenario where it's like live happening
right in the moment you can use the
synchronous API or you can use the
asynchronous API for larger chunks of
audio pre-recorded audio that you're
trying to transcribe so it works both
ways all right next up is what are the
resource requirements to run tensorflow
at the edge in a scenario like this on
an edge gateway the way I'd answer that
is I think the pure number people think
about is oh I can measure flops doesn't
really work that way because model
complexity drives and the model type
itself drives a lot of your resource
requirements so what I would say is
figure out the problem you're trying to
solve add a sort of small medium large
budget of like hey I have I'm running a
big server at the edge versus as I'm
running a low power device like start
from that that sort of gives you a
constraint on am i doing hundreds of
thousands millions or hundreds of
millions of neurons right you're
starting to think like that and then
from there benchmark and iterate and
what you'll find is that the the if you
if you had done a flop space measurement
it doesn't scale linearly
because as your as your compute at the
edge goes down different bottlenecks
show up like memory bandwidth and things
like that that would put that impact how
well the the model runs and then the
other side of the equation is also think
about if you don't need your inference
to happen in 30 milliseconds then that
really frees you up in terms of how much
compute you need at the edge we've we
have scenarios where we've deployed
effectively a Raspberry Pi and you run
super slow but it was good enough for
that scenario right six seconds to do
inference but that was good enough for
what we were doing so think of it that
way and then test and iterate and then
shrink your model as in when necessary
trading off accuracy basically your f1
score against the compute requirements
so alright looks like that's all the
questions yeah that's all we had so
thank you for joining us on this webinar
and again if you have any more questions
I do post them at the bottom of the
video we'll come back around and try to
answer all of them as well thank you for
joining us and we'll see you again soon
thank you